be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so as we get into our final video on the
Age of Apocalypse what I want to do here
is take some time to recap the events up
to this point as we discuss in our
previous videos the mutant Legion the
son of Charles Xavier travelled into the
past under the belief that if you were
to kill Magneto it would create a more
peaceful world for his father jumping in
the way of the killing blow Xavier dies
rather than Magneto and so what this
does is it creates a fracture in the
timeline affording apocalypse a chance
to launch his campaign of world
domination the taking the opportunity to
do so the story of Age of Apocalypse
picked up with Bishop traveling the City
of Seattle with apocalypse having
successfully taken over North America
now after a short battle between some of
apocalypses henchmen and eventually
coming into contact with Magneto Bishop
explains that this newt online is not
how things are supposed to be and that
all of this is due to the death of
Charles Xavier now after using the
powers of rogue to absorb bishops
memories magneto forms a plan to
assemble various artifacts from across
this alternate universe to ensure the
timeline goes back to normal the gambit
and his team will travel into space and
capture a shard of the m'kraan crystal
an artifact that has the power to reset
reality Colossus and Kitty Pryde would
travel to the Seattle core to rescue
magic or Illyana Rasputin the sister of
Colossus who has the ability to travel
into the past and Nightcrawler would
travel to the city of Avalon the last
safe haven for humans and mutants for
he'll enlist the aid of a woman named
destiny who's actually a blind mutant
with the ability to see into the future
now in addition to all of this we
learned that the mutant geneticist mr.
sinister had been experimenting with a
DNA of Jean Grey and Scott Summers to
create a being powerful enough to topple
apocalypse the following is creation and
subsequent release into the world
sinister eventually caught up with Nate
grey in an effort to see how his power
was progressing and so after sinister
manipulated the powers of May grey and
his emotions Nate grey sought to fulfill
his purpose by destroying apocalypse
himself now is the last piece of the
puzzle we learned that those humans who
were most prominent in the main level
timeline such as Tony Stark and others
existed as part of a group called the
human High Council as the last vestiges
of government in the world they sought
to end apocalypses regime the feeling
that can only be a
with the use of nuclear weapons the
human High Council used Wolverine and
Jean Grey to begin a mass evacuation of
all humans and mutants on the eastern
seaboard in order to ensure minimalism
see casualties in the explosions should
nuclear weapons become necessary now
with all these pieces moved into their
final places we pick up with an
inclusion of the Age of Apocalypse but I
also want to let you guys know ahead of
time because this is a 90 story things
move incredibly fast throughout the end
of this conflict
so picking up with Jean Grae what we
find is that her attempt who entered the
domain of apocalypse in an effort to
assist the x-men and overthrowing his
rule has landed her in the pens where
she's being experimented on by dark
beasts
however with Scott Summers
ever-increasing desire to move away from
the dark reign of apocalypse
he ultimately turns on both his brother
havoc and beast himself now while Scott
Summers is overpowered and held captive
Jean uses her abilities to remove his
optic cover allowing the full blast of
his energy beams to be unleashed and so
what happens is Cyclops effectively
takes out beast and knocks havoc
unconscious along with several other
hitch pin and together he and Jean Grae
escape the immediate confines of the
pens now from here we transition to
Magneto and Bishop and what we learned
is that following a breach in the
security system the two head outside to
investigate but realize that the
mansion's actually under attack from
some of apocalypses henchman now wallets
who are able to take these individuals
out with minimal effort this was all
revealed to a bit of ruse as apocalypse
himself arrives to confront Magneto now
I'd like you guys to pay particular
attention to this exchange because this
will actually be a major focal point
towards the end of the story in this
event but what apocalypse tells magneto
is that while he leads this group of
x-men in the memory of Charles Xavier
that magneto himself is inherently weak
while he was perceived to have been
strong at one time his willingness to
cast aside his cunning and crow behavior
has also caused him a luxury of doing
whatever it takes to succeed even if it
means the murder of innocent people
now while apocalypse himself has no
qualms with this behavior what we'll
find is that this sentiment will
actually be turned on him now in
addition to all of this apocalypse takes
notice of Bishop in his attempt to stop
apocalypse attack on Magneto now while
this is the first encounter between
Bishop and apocalypse in this story
apocalypse has learned through various
reports and direct monitoring of
Magneto's actions that Bishop is in fact
a time traveler looking to correct the
timeline but what apocalypse doesn't
know is the extent of bishops
information regarding the timeline how
it was changed and the actions of Legion
that led to this new reality and so what
apocalypse says is that his telepaths
will basically force their way in the
bishops mind and
and all the secret city has to offer now
from here we switch to the x-men as they
arrive following their evacuation of
civilians of mutants to the safe zone in
Europe where they learn that apocalypse
is taken both Magneto and Bishop now
realizing that the death of Magneto
would mean certain doom for this reality
either by the successive apocalypse and
taking over the world for the humans
destroy North America with their nuclear
weapons the x-men make the decision to
confront apocalypse head-on at his
headquarters now continuing this trend
with all these roads leading directly to
an effort to confront apocalypse we
transition to Scott Summers and Jean
Grey again now continuing their way
through the fortress in an effort to get
away the two eventually come upon havoc
and over here orders to eliminate all of
the mutants that are being held captive
by Beast now with the two of them
working together they're actually able
to orchestrate a blackout within the
pens itself taking all the power down to
the entire facility and so using the
opportunity to rally the captive members
to their side the Jean Grey and Scott
Summers basically lead these individuals
to freedom and now again continuing this
trend of this story moving at a very
fast pace we transition to gambit and
his team of externals following their
capture of a shard of the m'kraan
crystal while the group was able to
return to Earth with the shard in hand
what we learn is that there's actually a
traitor among their ranks after having
been previously captured and forced to
operate on apocalypses we have a Guido
one of the members of the team steals
the shard of the m'kraan crystal now
realizing the treachery is afoot Jubilee
flees back to the x-men mansion to alert
magneto but when it's actually revealed
that magneto had previously been
captured
she takes the son of magneto in a robe
for protection only to be confronted by
cuido himself and so overpowering
Jubilee and taking the child we know
hands both of them over to apocalypse
and so at this point we transition back
to Magneto as the final conflict begins
to come underway
while magneto isn't really being held
prisoner and the traditional sense that
he's being chained to a Cell his prison
is more of a prison of the mind with
apocalypse and Holocaust one of his
horsemen constantly taunting Magneto
however the duo is met with the arrival
of Nate gray and alongside Magneto that
you are able to confront both apocalypse
and Hollow
now in addition to this the collective
groups of gambit and the externals the
x-men and Bishop having previously been
rescued by the x-men themselves arrived
as well resulting in a full-scale battle
in the heart of apocalypses Citadel
while the group is able to distract
apocalypse magneto was able to speak
directly with Illyana Rasputin alongside
Bishop while Ileana admits to not having
any mutant powers magneto actually
states that these powers are dormant and
that with the m'kraan crystal she'll be
able to access her abilities by watching
various versions of herself using her
powers now well it's not explicitly
explained to us why it is this is able
to happen I would go as far as to say
that this is simply just introduced to
us for the sake of the story progressing
and allowing some sort of conclusion to
be written n but after accessing her
abilities directly Illyana Rasputin
opens a portal using the power of the
intron crystal and sends Bishop into the
past
during the conflict between Legion
Xavier and Magneto now picking up again
with Scott Summers and Jean Grey what we
find is that Jean Grey uses her powers
to realize that the humans have launched
their nuclear weapons against North
America and so with twenty minutes left
before detonation we find that Jean Grey
and Scott Summers are met with the
arrival of Wolverine as well as havoc
and that while havoc and Wolverine do
arrive separately the fact remains that
they each showed up chasing an
individual havoc of course showed up
chasing Cyclops and Wolverine showed up
trying to get Jean Grey to come back but
what we also learn here is that Jean
Grey has been using her mental powers to
effectively hold the nuclear weapons at
bay that while the nuclear weapons have
been travelling she's either been
stopping them entirely or slowing them
down in order to buy them more time but
with time running out very very fast
Jean Grey attempts to intervene between
the conflict of Cyclops and havoc and
ultimately she's killed by havoc and so
with his former lover killed wolf rein
retaliates by killing havoc himself and
so from here what we learn is that with
Jean Grey having been killed that the
timeline now officially starts the
timeline is at 20 minutes going forward
until complete and total nuclear
bombardment of North America and so from
here we jump back to Bishop into the
past confronting Legion before he kills
Xavier Bishop tells him that his actions
will result in a modification
the time line when which destroys
everything that Xavier had stood for now
while Legion is very skeptical of this
and legions actually engrained in his
attitude of believing that he can
genuinely change time one Bishop does is
he takes legions power and forces Legion
to read the mind of Bishop and when he
does Legion realizes that the Age of
Apocalypse will come to fruition that
the actions of Legion will not make a
better future for Charles Xavier but
instead will lead to the death of
Charles Xavier and a dystopian future
and so realizing that his actions would
be and the negative Legion effectively
relents and gives up his quest and so at
this point what we do is we jump back to
the main Age of Apocalypse event
happening itself and with Charles Xavier
having never died trying to save magneto
from Legion the Age of Apocalypse
corrects itself and turns into an
alternate reality and so with around
five minutes left before detonation the
conflict between the combined forces of
the x-men and apocalypse comes to a head
when apocalypse attempts to kill magneto
by choking him to death and so focusing
on his powers magneto actually kills
apocalypse by ripping his body in half
in one of the most infamous scenes of
the series and so what this does is this
basically again take the idea of
apocalypses belief system of survival of
the fittest and flips it on its head
that now apocalypse is the one who was
effectively found wanting
where magneto was the one who came out
on top and so with the forces of
apocalypse disbanding and running for
the hills we ultimately joined Magneto
their son Charles and rogue as they are
basically gathered together waiting for
the nuclear bombs to strike which at the
end of the story they do presumably
leaving us with the idea that the Age of
Apocalypse has been destroyed entirely
with that being said I know this story
went by very very fast but that's only
because of how was written the idea of
the Age of Apocalypse is very
fast-moving once it gets to the
conclusion and because of the 1990s
story there's really not much we can do
so thank you guys for being part of this
and I will catch you guys later peace